oh
there we are oh yeah
are we live where are you gonna assume
here i can see it
yeah i mean i haven't heard from nick
but i've just kind of seen my life
i'm just gonna do an intro are we live i
hear it all right
hi everyone and welcome to another
gamespot play for all
charity stream uh we've been running a
lot of these all week
bringing in friends of gamespot to help
raise money for an
excellent cause ablegamers so joining uh
myself
and tomorrow today we have steve spawn
from ablegamers
uh steve what are we doing today we are
going to be playing some marvels on
stream which is a fantastic game where
you get to be a marble on our track and
if you win tam may feel generous enough
to give you a teeny tiny little prize
oh yeah we've got some prizes we've
lined up courtesy of
big thank you to capcom playstation
and uh various uh publishers including
creamer
um humble bundle and then
fly school studios via mwm interactive
and then perfect world um who are very
kind enough to
donate um to us some incentives these
include
codes for these are north american codes
these are codes for
monster hunter world iceborn 355
championship edition mega man 11 we've
got ratchet and clank rift apart which
just came out
you'd love to see it maternal um sac boy
we've got mlb this show
we got oxen free eichenfeld stonefly
torchlight so
get involved a lot a lot of games to go
out plenty to go out so
um yeah make sure you're playing and
make sure you're also donating we are of
course raising money for
um ablegamers uh so go to the url
tinyurl.com
play for all 20 21 and please be
generous if you can't donate trying to
share the stream around so you might get
you know someone who can donate into the
stream hanging out and doing
you know supporting the effort yeah we
actually have like one uh one already uh
leon d
bauer uh fifty dollars so thank you very
much
and obviously reading those out and then
we had another coming
like ten seconds ago straight after from
an anonymous which was a hundred dollars
thank you so much
thank you um okay so steve
how do we how do we play yeah so it's
really easy
uh we sit here and we just talk about
how
amazing tam's hair is for the first
couple of minutes and then once we get
all kinds of amazing people in chat all
they will do is type exclamation mark
play and you'll hear me say that way too
many times in the next two hours uh and
it's a completely free game
you don't have to spend any money you
don't even have to donate although i
highly recommend for extra luck
uh just karma helps you with that uh you
know and then if you happen to be the
lovely marble who wins then you get
something from tam
yeah we'll send you a we'll send you a
cold at random
um i'll i'll say what code we're gonna
be playing for first
um and we're gonna whisper it to you in
in uh twitch chat we've got our very own
jean-luc
hiding away behind the scenes uh in
twitch chat who's gonna
dm you um so please do get involved
um i've been told that um donating
significantly helps your chances
i don't know how that works but uh let's
not question science
um that's how it works so please do
donate as much as you can
and uh let's let's you know have some
fun and raise some money for an amazing
cause
yeah yeah i'm excited for it for sure as
the uh is the week of uh playing games
been exciting for youtube so far
it's been you know what after e3 like i
was
towards the end of e3 where we were on
camera
for the entire day every day i was like
oh man i don't know if i want to do
another another week of
of of being on camera but then i was
like all right this is for charity
though and it's going to be way more
chill and the moment it started i was
like this is way better this is way more
fun
and like i've been having a great time
with it it's still tiring but like
knowing that it's for such a good cause
just helps push me
yeah and i think as well it's um it's
the week of like obviously you kind of
have the week of excitement from e3
and it feels more tiring to do e3 i
think because
this time we are hanging out with
friends like people who
have been on gamespot in various ways
over the years or folks that we
are friends with or people that we just
admire and chat to and want
any excuse to just play games together
and obviously we're doing it
in the name of charity in the wonderful
name of ablegamers and
it's a great excuse to get everyone
together and hopefully we'll raise a ton
more money we've already raised like six
grand
uh tinyurl.com playful2021 if you have a
few dollars to spare
um but it's like ablegamers is an
incredible charity and
we it's our 25th anniversary as well
and so we wanted to kind of take the
opportunity take all the hype and
kind of mind share coming out of e3 to
put a spotlight on it and raise some
money for it so yeah
that is kind of like the main objective
for us like like lucy said there we you
know e3
is around the time we get the most eyes
on our websites on our podcast
videos youtube that kind of stuff and
every year it kind of felt like a bit of
a
not a waste because you know covering
games is
is his own reward and we love doing it
but at the end of it it's just kind of
like a full stop and it was like oh now
if all of those people just disperse and
you know we have our our massive
audience and our audience will stick
around but the people that come in just
because it's e3
they just kind of leave so we were like
we should start just you know
kind of taking the opportunity to attach
a good cause to the end of it
and this year it's ablegamers and
hopefully we'll see the benefit of that
um but before before we move on um we've
read
a couple more donations come in we've
had a fifty dollars from imran
who said love all the work you guys do
and then routino
uh who's also in the twitch chat
currently uh gave 20
thank you so much awesome yeah routinea
was also the first person in there to be
like
morning all times got codes and
immediately play yeah
as well
my goal is to be the villain on this
stream and win every match so no one
gets the code
i keep all the codes so the no to our
friends out there who are not on twitch
the way that this program works
it only recognizes you if you type
exclamation mark play in twitch if
you're looking at us anywhere else
around the internets
it doesn't matter if you're on a phone
or a web browser but it does matter if
you're logged into twitch that's the
only way we can officially get you your
prize so please make sure you click on
that tab
yeah uh we have a bot in our youtube
chat kind of
just pointing towards twitch um mr
dreadful says i want to win the race but
i do not deserve prizes
what i think you deserve a prize
i think the the first prize we give away
is going to be a copy a digital copy
for the playstation 5 of sac boy a big
adventure
from our friends over at playstation
thank you to playstation for sending
that over
um so that's going to be the first one
we give away and also
chad please remember that if we call it
a code you
don't like or a system you don't own
remember still enter to play
and enter the win and tell your friends
about it because you can always give the
code away we don't care
if you give it away you sell it on the
black market for a million dollars it's
your code do whatever you want with it
yeah if you can have questions if
someone is selling for
a million dollars on the black market
please kick some of that to ablegamers
just a small fraction of it
no take ten percent that's fine yeah
we'll take ten minus three it's a fine
disease
that's right all right so let's get our
first round done yeah i wanna see
lucy honestly doing the the shot calling
here i think this is gonna be
spectacular okay i'm very excited oh i
can't wait let's go
here we go let's go so we got one minute
you got one minute countdown to enter if
you have any
stragglers out there you want to enter
exclamation mark play it's free you
don't have to pay any money you do have
to compliment tam's hair that's a rule
sorry oh thank you thank you thank you
thank you mr dreadful just finished mass
effect 3 last night needs more games so
you're in the right place
natural next step from mass effect
marbles that's right
stack boy you could probably make a sort
of mass effect-esque thing
in sackboy at this point or in little
big planet maybe not in second
yeah i mean sakuya is like just to talk
it up it's an absolutely delightful game
um so i would if you aren't already
playing i would chuck your name in there
hit the exclamation mark and play
because if you don't like it you
definitely know someone of a ps5 that
will enjoy it
here we go five seconds oh gosh here it
goes
you ready lucy hi i'm ready okay
okay let's roll all right all right i'm
gonna i'm gonna
play a camera okay anna you're here i'm
gonna zoom in here gonna start walking
and i can
and they're off wait oh hey so
love my boston is taking an early lead
but they're not following up for long
it's love my boston has taken the lead
it's taking the lead but
we've got k goodwin in 99 sh big slice
gaming coming in
wow oh wait now it's me
yes it's you you did it
i tried to i tried to wait and see but
i've fallen out i've fallen out of the
top 10 game spot as well
languishing at number 10 wow sun flash
kid going for it
that is the ghost ball so the cool thing
about the little blue thing in the
beginning that's the person who actually
won
the map overall if you happen to get a
world record
on these maps you stay in this game
forever as a ghost ball
wow a4 is
steaming away look at me i'm coming up
give me the code
fall into the wayside because tamar
briefly took the number one spot but
it's now
in there trying to get through the weird
swinging things
the games are coming in a number two
todd
where is uh todd is at fourth you hate
to see it todd was number one leading
the charge
so long gamespot is done
eliminated oh wait ghastly rub though
is doing all right puff coffee is
yeah big slice gaming
i'm just powering through doing
oh no the big slice gotcha oh no big
fat's got me
mr dreadful slow and steady
doing well for you i'm gonna slow down
time unless you do this on the right
bank
has just run away with it there i missed
the angle there
and that was a good game that was fun
congratulations
look at me three path five
speaking of number five here's tomorrow
look at this oh lucy you died at some
point i was gonna say i was like i don't
even know what happened to me
a good one is stuck oh no good one
will be whispering in your ear uh
your code congratulations
congratulations you've got a copy of sac
boys big adventure coming your way for
the playstation 5. i hope you've got a
playstation 5
because those things are like goldust
these days you can hold on to it
you know codes don't expire as far as i
know or you could sell it on the black
market or you could be
a you know a good samaritan and give it
to someone that does have
a a playstation 5. i am interested
though past
part five part of v do you have a
playstation 5 will you be able to enjoy
this game
what your what is your intent with our
code
what is your intention yeah
wait hang on i want to see what path v
says is it path v or is it path five
that's another thing that i also want to
know because it's going to be
calling i want to make sure it's path v
you know yeah i like that i like
v has come too nice look at that oh and
he was using the jerry ball that's
amazing
nice it's our alien we named them jerry
path v part 3 does not
have one what are you going to do
what are you going to do with your code
still your code we're not going to take
it away
your code your code is your code sadly
we don't have any copies of uh
demon cells to give away but tam hoards
those
like yeah those are all just mine no one
else can have them
so lucy is the announcer for the last
round uh you want the honor of choosing
one through 58 which one of these names
looks appealing to you
one through 58 i'm gonna go uh i'm not
even gonna look i'm gonna say
um 17. oh
wow very decisive 17 all right
the dojo are
[Music]
just before i moved um and in the
in the hubbub of my move i have sort of
fallen off but it's on my list like
i'm in the middle of it that in
castlevania so
first of all quick shout out to todd
todd
itil2t is t-o-d-d-i-22l-e
on twitch chat for the 20 donation thank
you so much
todd if we shout out cassette i'm just
going to call you tom todd
the next game we're going to be giving
away is torchlight 3
on the playstation 4 slash 5. you know
it works wherever you wherever you put
it
in the game torchlight free a good time
lots of loot
you know it's free don't complain donate
instead
we're doing don't forget y'all
you have to come i'm going to push the
start button now so you got a minute
you got to get over the twitch you got
to type exclamation mark play now the
cool thing
damn i don't know if you knew this but
over here on the left and the right
you can choose the different kinds of
balls you want to be you could be a
sheep
that's my emote yeah you could be a fox
you could be a penguin
all kinds of cool looks amazing yeah
that's a great great shout out from mr
dreadful don't hate donate
over there i love to hear it great great
work that's right don't don't be mad if
you don't win
just don't eat another dollar and the
karma fairy will bless you
with like a 0.0000
chance of doing that for sure we're at 6
345 i would love if we can get to 7 000
by the end of the stream we've got just
over
an hour and a half to do it i believe in
all of you please
big ted lasso hashtag believe energy
believe all right tim are you going to
try your hand at this one
let's go and we're off to the races
we are in in wow everyone's just
funneling into the exact same area not a
lot of movement currently happening
we've got lucy james kind of just
dawdling about not able to i am going my
own
way razzma razzmax
it's an elmo cupcake as well in at
number one currently is adam revlon
number two big contender tomorrow h
let's go buddy
let's get into more age that code for
torchlight
three for the playstation four and five
that would be incredible
and i've been uh pushing number three by
rammerman oh look at adam
oh adam was number one
flew too close to the sun is now off
absolutely gone the interesting thing a
part of this uh this map is there are
areas of this tube which
uh have uh are like inside so you can't
actually
fall off but then obviously there are
other parts of it where it's open air
and you can't go off the top
ramen has taken the number one spot
after uh
the untimely demise of the previous
number one leader
um i've moved down to number eight lucy
james not anywhere in the top 10 current
oh
doing pretty well there ag gone ghastly
rob gone
lost a couple of ash king gone we're
losing a lot of people here
a lot of deaths marvel's throwing each
other off the map
yeah i'm number one currently i was oh i
was number one for a hot second but 99
is number one now next network tv going
for it really going for it going down
what looks like some sort of poop canal
to towards the uh uh the gate at the end
there
all right let's start oh there he is tam
cam
and tam cam neck rick tv making a go of
it
i'm doing all right here we go we got
todd 20 donation todd i hope you win
this race against me for your 20
donation thank you so much
oh i'm gone i'm out oh he's out
have been really really going neck and
neck this entire time
oh 99 oh who got that 99
99 sh
[Music]
gengar my favorite pokemon oh hell yeah
you deserve that you've got great taste
in pokemon 99
congrats network tv put in a
valiant effort really really put in a
fight there so
um i hope that you you come back strong
for the next one
uh victor lasagna died right right now
uh 99 if you're in the chat let us know
will you be playing torchlight 3 on
playstation have you played the previous
torchlight games because they are a
great time
um and uh if not let us know what you're
going to do with your code jean look
we'll be whispering a code to you very
shortly
um also we've got a few donations so uh
now is iqbal
[Music]
frequent donator they pop in every
stream always donate uh gave five
dollars thank you narwhas
and uh trent wurtz gave twenty dollars
so thank you thank you
trent that's amazing um
99 we'll definitely be playing
torchlight oh yeah that's great
the next game next game we're going to
give away is a recent release called
stonefly
it's a steam game so you'll need to play
on pc
um but it's a it's a core game
it's worth checking out really
interesting ideas in it um
you may know that um the biggest tweet
of e3 was one belinda garcia talking
about sitting on someone's face
yes um yes belinda actually
actually worked on the narrative in this
game and so
there you go um you'll get you'll get
your opportunity to check out the game
it's a fun fun
time it looks wholesome i hope
um christian the world right exactly
nice
and as a reminder to our youtube friends
you gotta come over to the twitch side
the tight exclamation mark play
in the chat it's free it doesn't cost
you anything
as soon as you type exclamation mark
play you're in the game to win the game
and then from there it's up to the
marvel gods to determine
if you can beat tam and lucy in this
game and if gamespot wins
well then we just shut the stream down
we're just done for the entire day
so and as i've said my goal is to win
every match so only i get codes but
i failed so far so far so far i've still
caught
i don't think i've hit top ten either
time
you keep dying you i think the problem
is you're too furious too fast
yeah too fast and too furious op kenobi
let's go that is a great name ash king
seven number one
path v in the top 10 again really going
for it
um i loved the um what's the game in
pisces right that that beginning
reminded me of plinko oh it's like
klinko yeah
yeah which snoop dogg is weirdly very
good at
really really yeah so snoop dogg um
there's an amazing video on youtube
of him being on the price is right and
basically he says that he got like so
high and watched so much prices right
that he knows how to play all the games
really well
and he wins like a ton of money for this
woman he's paired with
it's very good that's amazing all right
you're not doing too well excuse me i'm
i'm trying a new thing i'm trying slow
and steady wins the race okay
um i have just dropped out of the top
ten so that's how that's going for me
good strategy all right i'm saying your
really fighting at it yeah all right
let's go lee
let's go i'm going for mr dreadful
i'm just they said they didn't they
didn't deserve a prize but i think i
just asked mr dreadful what is the
cheese picture
like i need to know the backstory behind
this cheese
as we watch the dab fall to their death
oh sorry dev
oh no oh mr dreadful donated 69 with
nice
thank you so much you definitely deserve
a prize
marbles are in your face i hope the
marvels are in your favor you're at
number one currently
it's looking good but lee i am obviously
on team lee because
uh i've decided that lee deserves a shot
at it
this is cool i don't think you're
allowed to choose size damn we have to
be objective
no this is just this is your favoritism
in my in my soul
okay okay yeah all right no no
i have no influence over this i just
pick every match i'm gonna pick one
person to just be a massive standoff
i thought you were saying you had no
influence over your soul i was gonna say
i don't think that's how that works
i mean you know i i can't say with
absolute authority that i have completed
with this oh no oh no i miss deadpool no
they just really like that cheese it's
really like cheese
that's that backstory behind the cheese
which i love this is see
see lee is just like clawing at number
one not
letting letting it go i love it okay
todd is there this is a battle right
here going back and forth between yeah
this is
uh okay i really don't even know who was
winning at this point this league keeps
changing hands
also
i'm still in it which honestly i'm just
happy to be there i really like how
happy you are as your marvel too your
marvel is very happy
you know yeah peace sign going on there
we go oh
todd's dead
[Music]
[Music]
boom nice congratulations lee
oh lucy's dead again what i'll come
on this is the most i've made it though
this this is like my tournament arc yeah
the league gabrielle thank you so much
for playing
announcing that yeah let us know if
you're if you're going to be playing
stonefly on pc
via steam um commiserations to emiliano
who came second
don't give up uh please keep trying
and please make sure you're donating
we've got a uh
a lot of donations already but we could
always do with more i just saw the mr
dreadful one coming on my screen
the 69 nice well played um as you
as you may be able to tell from the
on-screen graphics and
us talking about it we are raising money
of course for ablegamers an incredibly
good cause
um that combat social isolation and
makes gaming accessible for a
wide variety of people with various
disabilities and
it is a super super worthy cause so
please go to tinyurl.com for slash
playforall2021
and donate if you can if you can't
please do share it on
twitter or wherever you may be you know
in your dms in messages whatsapp
signal whatever messaging service you're
currently using um
you might know a whale you know someone
who's rich as hell
just feel like yo you've got more money
than you know what to do with how about
you don't buy a
thousand dollar sandwich and just give
that money here that's right how about
you not buy your seventh yacht and
instead
yeah exactly remember to hit exclamation
mark play if you want in on this one
the game we are going to be giving away
is going to be
mlb the show for the xbox series
x mlb the show 21
just came out recently broken free from
the sony
prison and is now available on microsoft
i feel kind of wily tam what do you say
what do you say we make a bet here
and uh and uh why don't you pick someone
and if they make it in the top ten you
give away
two codes oh okay i like it
i like it okay where you want to be
got a minute to choose i'm gonna i'm
gonna
bet on
honestly like mr dreadful is doing very
well
um
yeah i'm gonna bet on um
i'd get to city i think
that's the username okay get to city i
did get it we don't want to put any
pressure on here but
you need to get a pep talk to your
marble because if you talk 10 players i
get to see
i'm i've seen you doing i've seen you
doing i've seen you putting in the work
yep you've got a lot of potential ahead
of you this is your time
to really really challenge channel it
that's right if you win
if you just said bad
i need confidence believe in yourself i
need you to type in chat i will win
type in chat right now i will win feel
free to pep talk your ball whatever you
got to do
i i frequently have to talk my boss so i
let's go
keep in mind like this this is like a
secondary code city i feel like you know
yeah you could be the hero of chat
right here right now yeah yeah the
important is to get down the funnel
first this funnel can be a real log jam
so you got
it yeah this this is this is
reminds me of those little things that
like you'd see at like supermarkets
where you could put a quarter in it and
just give it to people yeah
mcdonald's would have one yeah why did
we give our change to mcdonald's anyway
i have no idea
i'd get to see not doing so well not
even a top ten right wait they're three
they're three are they
are they oh they were a second no that's
that's a routine maybe oh they weren't
they were for us
hold it a second i still believe i still
believe jamie mack 15
just running away with it though yeah
seriously jamie mike had a great start
okay well uh jamie oh there's there's
our friend ruchino
let's go let's see dreadful's back pork
marshmallow i have questions and also
i'm hungry
so um
[Music]
is that like we could put a marshmallow
on top of your pulled pork sandwich
oh that sounds like dangerous behavior
i don't know if you could put
marshmallows on sweet potato i think
anything goes with it
you can yeah um like
thanksgiving sweet potato thing i forget
what it's called
but i had it once and it was incredible
wow
jamie mac still commanding lead we've
got pork marshmallow coming in at number
two
op kenobi lucy are number one
okay you need to guide your balls into
the hole right there good job
well done coming down to the next level
yeah vicky lasagna's got the peanut
butter kid as is a display
picture
[Music]
oh well that did tell you was a bad idea
yeah let that be a lesson to you next
time when someone puts their faith in
you just reciprocate
reciprocate with confidence manifest
it's called chaos magic oh oh my god
lucy is in second place lucia number two
i win this one if lucy wins we take away
a
partner coming in or asking asking
asking has been in the top five a bunch
of times
oh yeah i think oh
number two though that's pretty good
you are the winner you are a proud owner
of
a copy of mlb the show 21 on xbox series
x let us know if you have an xbox series
x are you going to be playing mlb
the show do you like baseball or are you
deathly afraid of baseball they throw
balls
very quickly and it looks incredibly
incredibly dangerous
baseball scares me i'm learning this
about you
wait you have you ever been to see the
the giants
did we i i went yeah i went once oh yeah
and i was very sick at the time this is
pre-coded so
i was just normal sick i had i had a
tummy ache
um but uh yeah i had to leave early but
it was fun ash king does not have an
xbox series x but now you have does it
not work on an
a1 it might do
yeah i think it probably does yeah it
works on an xbox x's
1x as well so if not you can i'm sure
you know someone who would be interested
and now you can hold that code over
their head
and figure out what you can get them to
do for the code
like you could do like ask them to make
you a sandwich for a week anytime you
ask
for a code that's worth it do that i'm
going to introduce you now
to the most annoying map
in the past this is the hardest
map to predict because it's all about
portals it's just like the game you have
to enter one portal and come out the
other one and hit the right spot
so if you want to come in and play this
one it's exclamation mark play
it's free to play you have to be on
twitch but otherwise
uh so if you're gonna do the betting
thing again tam you better bet on
someone who's really skilled at the
portals
i think i think i'm going to wait and
see more matches
and then figure out who's looking like a
good favorite
but the game we're going to give away is
called oxenfree for the playstation 4
all five
is very good fantastic game developed by
night school studios um really really
great indie game um i think it's like
maybe like five or six hours
um but absolutely incredible um
very very cool you can play on your
playstation 4 or you can play on your
playstation 5 exclamation mark play
you've got 10 seconds
time to read donations because there's
one that's been uh addressed to you
oh yeah oh imran i think it's i
i'd get to city says uh please forgive
me tomorrow and donated 50 dollars
i believed in you then and i still
believe in you now imran
that's right um i want mama higgs
i'm i'm i've got a good feeling about
max
okay okay so uh let me walk you through
this you see those portals off in the
distance here this is the meaning oh
yeah
right here we're just going through as
soon as you go through this with
pathways about to do is drop through the
portal and drop through the sky
oh i love the bullet time wow bullet
time action look at that so then you got
to go up this long runway here
and you have to get past these beginning
pegs right here which is really
difficult to do and then you have to hit
it at the right angle to
jump over that endpoint this is dreadful
in the chat
says i greased up my marble this time
let's see how that uh grease works for
mr
i feel like it's only a matter of time
before mr dreadful gets
a win well
[Music]
you are now the proud owner of a
copy of oxenfree on playstation 4 slash
five
have you played luxury before will you
be playing oxen free now let us know in
the chat
i if you don't you should definitely
play it um
it's real good look at how devastating
it was look how many people i was
unbelievable sorry it's in the chat just
says wow
and we'll be they will be playing yay
let us know what you think of it
uh hit us up on twitter and tell us what
you're thinking about
yeah and then making a sequel they are
making a sequel that was one hell of a
track
is there a number here that you're
feeling lucy got to pick earlier
oh yes of course we have to pick number
69.
that's that's way above 58 that's not
how that works
yeah what if you did six six plus nine
or six
or nine well i'll do six for now
okay and then i'll do nine next and
it'll be nice overall
i like that that's what i go for on my
dating apps is nice overall
nice overall yeah exclamation mark play
before i get myself in trouble uh tam
what are you thinking of the marvel's
experience so far
i am i'm i am absolutely loving this
this is incredible
um and yeah i i watched a bunch of this
in advance and um listening to thank you
for picking this
no no i've seen your streams i've seen
your streams over before
so like i was like this is cool and now
being part of it is
is like um is way more fun like being
able to shout cast it is fun and
and giving people the opportunity to win
things and the next thing being
an xbox one copy of mega man 11. thank
you to capcom for sending that in
that's a fun game obviously uh that will
be xbox one so
i i think it works on siriusx as well
yeah anything anything you can play on
on a one will work you're good uh mega
man 11
a real fun game so make sure you're
hitting exclamation mark play
um to jump in you've got 10 seconds in
twitch
on twitch i mean just like in youtube
some folks in in
albert hood in the youtube chat oh is
this not jenna marbles
she left youtube a year ago and we are
still sad about it
um remember if you if you didn't make it
in this one you can take the time
to one think about how quickly you need
to type to make it into the next one and
also think about donating to tinyurl.com
forward slash play for all 2020 money
goes to a fantastic cause
we're trying to get to seven thousand
dollars by the end of this stream
we've got uh just over an hour left so
please
chance ago sure ramaman says will it
work on my commodore 64.
sadly not so chat what do you say will
you will you enter a pact with me here
and and after we just saw the
devastating losses of our own
lucy james wow if she manages to get
top five chat will you donate a dollar
to ablegamers what do you think
that would be great that would be
amazing if lucy gets in top
top uh five i will donate ten dollars
oh my gosh okay
anyone in chat want to match the bet
let's go correct lucy
we're believing in you here oh ten
dollars or one dollar
oh anyway lucy now we'll do 10
chat can do one yes yeah if you want to
join us in ten
then what did we say top five or top ten
uh i believe we started at top five but
uh oh she's two now well um
we've got a few people we've got a few
people who are in there who are ready to
match it come on lucy
oh narrowly threaded through there she
needs someone to give her a bit of a
break
the needle oh
it looks like we've got a winner sadly
lucy didn't make it to the top okay
we'll give you another we'll give you
another chance later on we'll give you
another chance later on
uh but the winner is it's charles 89.
it's charles what's winning the entire
match by the way
it's charles cleaned up so it's charles
89 oh thank you
oh amazing you have a copy of mega man
11 coming to you
for the xbox one which you can play on
any xbox console i guess current xbox
console
um uh chat the minutes but yeah i know
steve you just said like
uh your chat uh talks cause of the buzz
mackers
our chat han just said i put lube on my
marble
and then uh tutti said i'm scared to ask
what you do with the lubed models
so i also have questions and if you
if you win three times in the same night
i have to have one of my mods check you
for a ball enhancement steroids
oh that's great yeah
charles it's charles 89 um please enjoy
your code are you a mega man fan
um do you intend to play it this could
be if you're not a mega man fan this
could be the moment you fall in love
with
everyone's favorite blue bomber who
isn't at least a semi mega man
fan that little blue guy is amazing he's
amazing i feel like if you
if you uh have even the smallest amount
of interest in video games
you you are you're a mega man fan by
default remember
exclamation mark play in the twitch chat
to play
the next game we are giving away it's a
big one
it is returnable for the playstation 5.
oh you're going to have a good time
you're going to have that as a game of
the year contender developed by house
mark published by sony exclusively for
the playstation 5.
get in there remember to also donate if
you can i've been told reliably by our
friends at twitch that donating
to charity it makes your chances of
winning incredibly
higher so please donate donate now
donating to charity
will um clear
your skin uh more energetic yeah let's
see how much more trouble can i get tam
it
guarantees you a sports car the next
time you go to the track
once again big shout out to christine
over at playstation who sent
us the codes for all the playstation
games super appreciate it
you know tim they make great gifts too
so even if you don't have a playstation
yet because they've been super hard to
get ahold of you can make a playstation
fan in your life really happy by giving
them
exactly present for sure
and we're off to the races oh man
lucy you want to give another shot at
the shot calling here yes go on okay
where are we at um
also my fire detec my fire detect smoke
detector is starting to beep
help that's what that's the batteries
the battery is low uh okay we're gonna
go down
the some kind of digestive tract
and now we're at the butt smackers
how are we going to get through all of
this victor lasagna with one of my
favorite
vines as the
doing well going down the center path
trying to stay
on course but let's go back to victor
lasagna
where have they gone for another one
a previous winner but dab 198 is
up front but they've just dropped to
number two but they're back again
it's a constable
jamie mac lee gabrielle and dab have
been
fighting it out ah lee gabriel trying to
go for another win
this round obviously for the game
returner
me trying my best
you got held up by the butt smacker
again
the butt smacker is my weakness uh
lee gabriel back in again at number one
but quickly the
narino and victor lasagna are taking
those number one spots
it's anybody's game it's a game of two
hobbes
i'm trying to think of like footballs
these kids are coming with passion
they've really raised the
uh the the they've raised the team
spirits
uh look at these balls trying as hard as
they can to win the night
look at this slo-mo over the sleeping
policeman
that might be a british phrase i don't
know if you call them that i think it is
feed bumps jamie mac going out jamie mac
picking up a bit too much speed this
could be dangerous for jamie mack
jamie mack is definitely barreling ahead
but these turns are becoming incredibly
treacherous
every just a pixel pixel away from
slipping over it was close
that was very close luckily slowly yeah
oh no just slow enough
for oh no jamie oh no jmx
previous winner defending reigning
defending champion oh
tam called that one that was a dangerous
game of speech yeah that was uh
that was incredible everyone's kind of
like jacob
lucy's off i'm done robots
transfers robots wins
trent out of nowhere i did not see sure
versus
robots coming out of nowhere and just
taking the win
what a fantastic effort no one expects
all the robots versus roblox
you have a copy of return for the
playstation 5 coming your way
john look is going to whisper it to you
congratulations
are you are you do you have a
playstation 5. i i'm really interested
in knowing whether where these codes are
going to end up
you know um so let us know if you've
played if you're interested in it or
you're going to gift it
what do you reckon you're going to do
with that code for eternal
oh penguin yeah a little penguin as well
yeah oh
cute oh bloody hell my fire alarm i
smoked
it can you hear it yeah you're good nice
it's doing the
like the ping every minute so
that's the battery the low battery for
you trying to remind you that it's still
alive
um trend versus robots does not have a
playstation 5 yet but
can hold on to that or gift it to
someone you never know that's right it's
your code you do what you want
yeah sell it on the black market for 1
million dollars if you can pull that off
let us know how you did it
uh we got some donations in trentwood
says ten dollars thanks for trying lucy
i donated ten dollars because i tried uh
and then root chino
5.59 don't mind me just cleaning up the
numbers and getting some good luck karma
you'd love to see it thank you so much
the next game we're going to give away
we're going to go back to um steam
we're going to give away a little game
called temtem oh
a fun pokemon like game if you've not
played tempt him
it's really cool we had a few pokemon
fans in the office become really
obsessed with it hit exclamation mark
play
in the twitch chat and you'll be entered
as a marble while you're waiting for the
game to start go to tinyurl.com four
slash playful 2021
if you've got some cash that you can
kick that way please do that will go to
ablegamers charity
super super beneficial um in you know
combating social isolation and helping
people with disabilities to
um make gaming more accessible for them
now and in the future
we're trying to get to 7k we got 500
we got 490 to go i believe in everyone
in this chat
and everyone watching around the world
and i think so it is like uh also
amazingly
links with like google pay amazon pay
so if you have log in to either of those
you don't need to worry about going and
getting a car
you can just log in to your bezos box
and and hopefully donate some money in
chat and it doesn't it
uh it doesn't take the thousands of
dollars that you think to help the
person with disabilities the average
controller cost is only 350 dollars that
is something that you can
get together with your friends and
family and raise that much money that
much
changes the life of one person with
disabilities who's then able to enter
the world of gaming that we know and
love absolutely
15 seconds once again we are going to be
giving away temtem
on pc by steam thank you so much to
logan
47 [ __ ] us up with that all right i
normally
say team here but i'm going to say you
here who do you think
is gonna come in top three um
[Music]
susie beagle oh i have a good
feeling about susie ash king seven
currently at number one and victor a lot
of the same faces
putting in the work here these marbles
they've all seem to have greased them up
real well we've got emilio ash king um
to the ce uh imran going at it but who
will be the ultimate victor
i kind of feel like we're going to have
an outsider just
sneak in at the end again just like we
had away with trent was it trent vs
roberts it was yeah
yeah um jacob
and jacob in there yeah and number um
so far once it's not been good for any
of us to call someone's name out because
apparently it's a curse of some kind
yeah i'm not seeing susie anywhere on
the top ten so
he hates lone steady slow and steady
yeah and once again we've been reliably
informed that donating
using the link tinyurl.com 2021 does
increase your chances permanently
so if you donate once your chances
increase somehow and it stacks as well
so if you keep donating um
it just gets higher and higher and
higher chances so that's right can we
get a disclaimer in chat real quick uh
yeah oh my god lucy oh no
susie beagle but wait susie beagle has
like the full
um what do you call it like a box around
her name yeah yeah
yeah she's a professional mother little
green symbol above it means she's in the
top 100 of all marvel players in this
movie
it does yeah she's so marvel's is
competitive
[Music]
seven wins that's two wins third rule
and somebody from chad will be by to
check your ball ash
so keep up mm-hmm
king seven you have a copy of temtem
coming your way you've already got
uh mlb the show now you've got a pokemon
like game as well on the way
tell us give it you know let us know
what your what are your intentions with
our beautiful ash
uh a copy of tempting ashkin seven tell
us
um
yeah you'd take it so yeah that one uh
you literally just like
exclamation mark play whenever we do
another map there is nothing else to do
uh you'll see people in chat typing
things like exclamation mark boost
exclamation mark swirl and dual barrel
roll none of that works if it makes you
feel better to do it go ahead and type
it you can't
just do anything just type to play
just like earlier when we were talking
about donating to increase your chances
it is entirely a placebo based on fake
science
so um anything you type in there it's
just for feel good feelings
that's right um thank you to mama higgs
for the fifty dollars
thank you so much i hope that means you
are blessed with the
the karmic marbles uh in the next round
what a great cause thanks for doing this
thank you for donating hope you get
extra
grease on your marbles
the next game we're going to be giving
away is a personal favorite of mine
it's for the playstation 4 but works on
the playstation 5 as well
it's a little game called street fighter
5 champion edition
one
this one we get to do a tour of the
solar system
okay 355 a fantastic game and the
champion edition has a lot of the dlc
that has been released since
initial release um very very
feature-rich game
i reviewed it and gave it a very high
score i still play every now and then
it's great
so make sure you hit exclamation mark
play to enter yourself in there
and while you're waiting for them to
begin donating two champions in there
too so
yeah i tweeted it out after lucy did and
uh i think some of my people saw we got
two
champions uh so if they have a little
green symbol above their head
not a joke it really does mean they were
top 50 of the last season oh wow
professional marvelers in here now wow
we've got
oh marvel players yeah because if you
get top three you see those little uh
bouncing graphics on top of the screen
yeah that is their graphics so if your
top three you get to choose a graphic to
put in the wow
yeah instead of typing play you just use
their little graphic that's pretty cool
wow okay
we will win this copy of 355. jacob says
who's lucy going to jinx this round
uh and for saying that i think it's
going to be
jacob mccourt oh god
you got a real card in jacob i was going
to say reverse
reverse well this is
not we've got more more new new marbles
in the top ten here but we do have some
old faithfuls in there as well number
one currently is me
give me that code for 355. let me have
it
yes go go my beautiful marble
mr dreadful is hot on your case though
oh
no i quickly got bounced out of it yeah
they're really close behind you uh i'd
like to see jacob
jacob is trying to stay and talk to him
so far not been able to do it with the
curse
i just want i want everyone like in the
top 10 to just kind of
you know fly too close to the sun and
then jacob just sneak up and get it
except the time is like
oh sam is taking the lead again now holy
crap tim really likes this game lucy
yeah he
hacked the system the wario is now
beating tam oh no
oh no burps there's number one bubs are
slowing down though
yep i've dropped down to number 10. i've
dropped down to number 10.
no just like just like my career on the
street scene i have fallen off very
quickly
you thought you had it and then you just
fell off yeah
for a hot minute first time again hey
falling back again oh okay oh there he
is there he is
can he do the speed bumps
[Music]
or slowing down though yeah a lot of
yeah
yeah i've just
i'll deny you a code one of these days
thank you we should know tam didn't even
get top 10 after all that time winning
yeah i always it truly is anyone's game
oh i actually i actually finished this
time though you do much like my much
like my life i start strong and then
spot her out
um thank you uh to burp stuff for saying
go banana
and pork marshmallow says hey i didn't
fall off the map so yeah
true you told her let us know uh whether
you're going to be playing street
fighter
5 champion edition are you a fighting
game fan do you want to become a
fighting game fan street fighter 5
got a comprehensive um suite of training
so i would love to hear that you are
interested in learning how to play it
you play that game learn how to play you
can probably transfer a lot of that
skill to other recent fight games like
joey guess drive just came out you could
try that as well
um let us know what you thought you're
so cool my favorite character yells get
over here it's great it's amazing
i i will not rise to this steve i will
not allow you to do this to me
lucy where would you like to go next um
oh hang on i've seen something called
eye of the story at number 10. oh
this one's a hurricane we've got two
donations quickly we've got it's charles
89 gave 20
said you people are the best and then
lee winner lee
gave two dollars and said thank you all
thank you thank you thank you lee
congrats on winning uh exclamation mark
play
in the twitch chat if you would like to
join the game we are going to be
yeah like the number one two three four
five after exclamation mark play to be a
different kind of ball you can choose
your ball on the left-hand side
the game we are going to give away is a
game
called i can fell on pc
i can feel is a really cool game um
kind of an rpg but it's got a super
diverse cast
and gamespot awarded it gamespot's
jordan remake
um was very praiseworthy of it um in
terms of its music
and its uh narrative so uh
definitely worth checking out um coming
to the pc
if you don't have a pc and you don't
have access to steam you can always gift
it to someone
or if you manage to you know convince
someone that it's an an nft you can sell
it for millions online who knows
good luck oh we've got a dollar donation
from
pixel by pixel pixel studios
studios thank you so much thank you
yes the makers of marvel's on stream
you have created something amazing here
thank you yeah this is so cool this is
incredible
all right rouchino at number one right
now
victor lasagna true story when uh i was
trying to get
my marbles uh emote in the game i was
like listen
we should be friends because i'll be on
game spot one day
and you should uh make friends with me
now because then you get to meet tam
here you go here's tim oh hell yeah
hello i'm glad to i can meet you i would
love to see
my face on a marble oh that'd be great
no actually that would be horrible don't
do that
that would be awful
horrible chimera rolling around like
a dog
yeah i don't know how this is going on
something oh my gosh
look at jamie uh
so close to jamie i can fall coming your
way
not only do you get like a fall but also
jojami should whenever we
play on gamespot again you now have
this amazing marvel's record you're
going to see yourself as a ghost ball
right yeah hang around i don't know
forever
love to see it ah pixel by pixel in the
chat
uh saying i hope the races are going
well or yes thank you
and thank you thank you so much thank
you for the donation
to jamie you up for playing some uh
i can fall or you're gonna gift it to
someone else let us know
uh in the meantime uh remember that you
can donate
using tinyurl.com forward slash play for
all 2021
or type exclamation mark donate in chat
yeah
um the next game we're gonna give away
is a big one
it is a video game called ratchet and
clank
rift apart
oh steve's never heard of it but it's a
little indie game
there's a little engine called from
manor and clank
what yeah sp spanner and dank ripped
the font the red so far it's nice yeah
that's right
playstation 5 9 out of 10 gamespot.com
talk of the town currently i want this i
don't want anyone in the chat to have
this
i need to win this i am i'm entering
myself
well you can't
this is like one of the biggest games
we're going to give away today so chad
i'm going to give you a little bit of
control here
type exclamation mark vote followed by
the number of the map you would like to
play
whoever gets the most votes that's the
map we're gonna do
and that's that's whether or not you're
gonna win okay
sadly the maps don't go up to 69 we
already tried it yeah 58 is the max
sorry
um i just tweeted out again just because
obviously ratchet is a huge it's a huge
game so get some more folks in who
yeah let's let's let's give let's give
folks like a couple minutes to jump in
um the temple of steve is currently
winning i like that i'm gonna
yeah i'm gonna say pixel by pixel won't
tell me that that map was dedicated to
me but i think it was
okay goodwin says i would like to win
this one please so if everyone could
just forfeit that'd be great all right
looks like we're going to temple of
steve for the big game all right
lucy tam welcome to my temple oh
glad to be here one minute chad come in
one minute this is your one minute
warning get in
[Music]
i am giving all my support to myself
to yourself yeah i i do
oh pixel by pixel themselves and trying
to win this game
the developer of the game wants a copy
of ratchet and clank he'd love to see it
this is how hot it is let's go i can't i
can't cannot wait to stream this game on
my on my
uh off off uh gamespot streams as well
i'm so excited about this
if you wanna you wanna co announcer let
me know i'm happy to do it with you this
is fun
awesome mr dressler says in this economy
you may have a ratchet or a client
more than likely
thank you thank you great oh we got 50
people in here you got a 1 in 50 shot of
win in this chat
so i won't jinx anyone i won't call out
anyone else's elsa's name
lucy calling herself out here wow well
look i know that i'm
i'm jinxed i game of adam number one
sith moon weaver is in there
sip moon revo yeah oh a duel no lucy's
in
top ten i'm in top canal i just dropped
out
pixel by pixel studio getting in there
circling the drain a lot of marble
circle in the drain current
here we go oh no we were out in front
moon weaver early commanding lead i see
emery
imran imran's coming in enough to come
in he wants that game
see excellent strategy here by superman
we've got taking it slow
we're having enough speed to keep
momentum
and not picking up too much speed really
hit an impulse here though
hit an impasse here
[Music]
might have to split it one of you get
rash one don't you get pink
oh safe movie in the chat is like wow
oh no you're back here at number one are
you still there you're still there don't
give up
you're doing good you're doing good
you're doing okay yeah sam tells me if
gamespot wins right here
in this marvel we're going to give away
a thousand copies of this game out of
his own person
wow yeah thank you tam
i mean like it will bankrupt me but you
know i'll think about it
pork marshmallow coming in number oh
look they got like a cool little symbol
for their names
yeah ash king seven this would be
ashkin's third win
win this will be one win and they will
be inspected for ball tempering
asking seven oh my lord
wow i could where's the knight family
corpse is close by though
number two
pick up too much speed and go over the
top though that is the question
good one let's see top five game of adam
back here
observing the top five okay looking
purposely not saying people's names
i don't want to jinx anyone i'm gonna
leave it on time slow just to keep the
the attention building detention going
ash king seven
uh someone in a chat oh someone in chat
asking how to enter you hit exclamation
mark
um play but not in this not in this
round this round has begun
asking seven
points because you have to follow
through the right side when the box is
on your side otherwise you die a painful
marble death
it's anyone's game ratchet and clank
features a character called dr nefarious
so it'll be an apt test
of marble strength so ash is on one side
farming is on the other
oh yeah we got famicobs game of adam
siphman weaver
dj all battling it out first who's gonna
get through
todd coming in oh this is so
nerve-wracking
i can't watch i have to watch that in
the camera oh okay
sith moon weaver may be going through
ash king seven
close by no see if we were not going for
a game coming in there
yeah we tried that oh my god okay wow
oh the box is moving again oh no
moon weaver you're in trouble
[Music]
of course i'm
you win a copy of ratchet and clank rift
apart for the playstation 5 our very own
jean-luc
will be whispering it to you family
corpse do you have a playstation 5
and are you excited to check it out i
want to point out let us know
you were only three spots away from
having ten thousand copies of wretched
drink
damn i'm glad i lost that one honestly
thank you to sif moon weaver for the
thirty dollars and
thank you for your rock thank you thank
you so much
great great effort there i feel like we
had this isn't
i feel like this isn't the last we've
seen of sith moon either no
no i feel like moon weaver has will only
grow more and more powerful
i mean it just goes to show you that
obviously there's no riggedness here
because the uh the purple name right
there that's the developer of this game
believe me they could have rigged it
they would yeah they could have
right there type in the secret code give
tam to give me the game
famico says thank you so much you're
very welcome great
great yeah welcome personal munchies got
six
and is willing to take that fantastic um
and uh pork marshmallows
uh not like this i fell off again
i hate to sit not like this you truly
hate to see it
um marbles is they also have these
incredible community maps
where you see some of them have some
very high elimination
rates and some of them oh wow this one
right here do we have this much time uh
this one goes for 31 hours
uh oh wow one hour
i'm down if you are all right let's go
then the next game we're going to give
away is torchlight 3
again okay um we got a few codes for
torchlight three and also stonefly and
oxenfree and
uh after giving away a massive game like
you know
uh ratchet and clink we need to build it
back up to that again and torchlight
three is a
fantastic game too 20 elimination
that we want to bring back giving away a
second
game oh yeah okay
okay so what's the rule here steve uh
well if you're you're gonna pick a
person and if they get into the top 10
you're going to give away a second copy
of something of i'll give away a second
copy of torchlight so there's two
chances to win torchlight here
and i am going to go with you know what
no yeah
who whoever wins right like you gotta
admit like if they get six or nine
that'd be great right
yeah that would be good that would be
good
um give you a minute on the clock to
pick
your favorite person
i'm gonna i'm gonna throw throw it
behind chef moon weaver
red weaver you're up either all right
moon weaver if you want to type anything
to your marvel
to pep talk it now's your chance yeah i
need you to give your marble a good pep
talk in the chat please
if moon weaver okay
all right now while we're winding yellow
says join me
please all right i'm gonna disappear
from camera for one second to grab a
quick drink of water and
be back in 20 seconds i'll leave this
all right
lucy's hands oh no
time souls bias is showing yep
absolutely
uh i'll i've just put the donation link
into the chat there
and for those that want to please donate
cleans your skin good comic energy into
the world
hopefully you can cash out for a game
uh that we're giving away we have codes
for tam
what else we've got left you're in
charge of our spreadsheet we've got a
bunch of codes we've got more torchlight
three codes we've got more awesome free
codes we've got more stone flare codes
we've got mlb this show
we've got another sac boy we've got
monster hunter and a few more
there might even be one more ratchet
code
oh oh this is wild who we got
i love this this is a lot this map is a
lot it looks
lee gabriel again in at number one
saw that uh they've kind of another back
down at number one again
where is fifth moon weaver where are you
come on i believe in you oh there is a
pile up
there's a junction here
oh everyone's whoa
wow what is going on here i never
noticed these sounds
before pathway
path and the great the great fat boy
number two
i was going to go for the great fat boy
before i picked super moon weaver
because of the
dark souls reference i don't reference a
very nice message in chat
uh when they joined earlier to say that
steve was great and that they were
loving the stream i'm
dead so is chris hayner hi chris uh
um again another pile up
a huge pile up okay goodwin asks is so
reversing original dark souls it
is absolutely that's where from software
should we make it
something game of adam's looks the game
get it adam and admin
copy of torchlight for the playstation
4. play
playstation 5 coming towards you
i missed it it didn't sit when we were
top ten no this is
if moonweaver
you know sometimes you win them
sometimes you lose them for me
i just keep losing them all right lucy
you're the picker for the rest of the
map because damn
yeah i am not good luck these community
maps are great because they're sparkly
they've got sound effects they're really
pretty fun
game of thrones will you be playing
torchlight
or will you be gifting it have you got
any experience with diablo like games
or do you want to get experience in it
because there's a really quick one
that lasts like only a minute and a half
an impressive time if you ask me uh 24
elimination oh for this
yep for this yeah you might want to have
a go with another oxen-free level coach
yeah i think oxenfree is a good one
oxenfree's great
so um winner of this one wins a copy of
excellent video game
oxenfree make sure you hit exclamation
mark
play in the twitch chat yeah and
we're trying to raise get to 7k we're at
6712
so please do donate if you can
tinyurl.com forward slash play for all
um in the description
it's everywhere if you search any of our
twitter names i'll be there too
you can donate very easily via apple pay
google pay whatever it may be
amazon pay amazon pay bazel sparks all
of it
basil yeah freebase that's been in my
head all day like i've got delivery
today that's been in my head it's in the
petition to uh
not let jeffrey bezos back onto earth
after his rocket trip
has he gone yet madden he's not gone yet
all right here we go let's see who's to
win a copy
of oxenfree mr jeffers says you can show
up at tom's house with a bag of nickels
um yeah yeah i mean tom would then have
to take it to the bank
and get that all counted but yeah we
will accept that
okay this this looks like a kind of a
wide open funnel here
not like the log jammer we thought yeah
much kind of funnel this looks like the
mcdonald's funnel
a little bit
[Music]
ash king at number one currently oh my
god oh my god ash king we might
give us your secrets ash king we might
have to cut you off you're winning too
many of these codes
oh no they got they got caught by speed
bumps sorry
has also won once so interesting
apparently the experience of the
marvelers is really helping out here
oh yeah oh don hetcher that was great
just coming in using the boost oh
[Music]
you have a copy of oxygen free for the
playstation 4
5 coming towards you via whisper
yeah please enjoy it amazing
uh steve moon weaver and chad says lucy
stephen i just want to say thank you for
all that you do to raise awareness and
money for great causes
you are all awesome thank thank you
steve for donating
like that's the best thing
speaking of donations we've got a couple
more so let's just take a
brief uh break to mention these we've
got cody f.s
schmidt um who donated 15
and then charlie donated 20 and said
love the works
you guys doing and glad to see so many
great guests taking part
thank you so much we are now at 6747.
and we're trying to get to 7 000 by the
end of the stream
we've got around 40 minutes to do it
um and
we've got copies of still we've got a
few more
torchlights we've got a few more stone
flies we've got a few more oxenfree's we
got
proteus we've got um mlb the show 21.
we've got another sack boy
we've got street fighter we've got mega
man we've got monster hunter world i
spawn
and we have one more
ratchet and clank rift apart we got a
nice
four percent elimination here tam on a
two minute map so it's a pretty decently
long half called big hot
you know what i'm gonna go with a
i'm gonna go with proteus on steam
proteus yeah proteus an interesting game
uh
it's got a lot of good reviews it's got
a 10 out of 10
on steam wow um it's it is a
fun first person shooter um
and it's in it's a classic old-school
style
first person shooter um reimagined using
modern rendering techniques it is
beautiful to look at
and it is yeah it looks like a really
really fun game if you like
doom this is the kind of game that
you'll be into is of course for steam so
um make sure that you've got a pc if not
you can always just give it away to
someone
and make another pc gamer's life um
better by giving it away
classic boomer shooter someone says in
chat it's the classic boomer
shooter exclamation mark play
to join uh pork marshmallow says proteus
is on my wish list so fingers crossed
for you that you will win
in this round exclamation mark play got
a few more seconds
seven six i'm i'm pulling for you
um pork marshmallows proteus
video game let's go let's go
okay wow look at this that's an amazing
avatar
if i win it i will give it to uh
pork marshmallow oh do they have to buy
you dinner
yeah okay i like this giant golden
threaded screw here that we're going
down
seemingly to death i don't know if this
is spiraling down
is that a big light it's just a big old
light bulb yeah
remember if you type in exclamation mark
boost it does literally nothing but it
will make you feel good
that's right it's like it's like when
you play um
a racing game and you do this it's the
same it's the same effect
mario kart but you try to like throw the
controller up to jump because if
i just want to say a huge shout out to
uh dave jewett
game sportszone dave dewitt and my
housemate who's taking the battery out
of the smoke detector
i know you can't hear it but it was
driving me
wild mr dreadful colony are number one
about to go into this deus
ex
that looks like an anus but we'll not um
reflect too much on that uh just some
weird
stuff going on there's like it's like
grabbing you and pulling you through
like a sphincter mr mr dreadful fox of
the future and the great fat boy have
been battling it out for so long right
now
uh who knows who's going to win it sadly
pork marshmallow not near the top right
now
i jinxed you i'm sorry i'm feeling mr
dreadful here i think
yeah it's looking good i think you you
should never count out a fat boy
and so it's a great fat boy dreadful
boy wow
absolutely rigged
you have a copy of a proteus coming your
way
marshmallow says i probably fell off i'm
sorry
that might have been my fault dreadful
i'm so sorry you didn't win i thought
you had it in the miami come out of
nowhere and just took the game from you
yeah that's so fun part about marvel's
man there's people just come out of
nowhere they just win
it's great it just went great map from
jamie mike 15. look at what miami said
in chat
can i give my code to the person that
wanted it
oh that is beautiful you absolutely
can that's amazing
that is amazing that that is a nice
that's so nice miami so that code that
code
john luke if you haven't sent it already
please send that code to
pork marshmallow that's so nice thank
you if not me amber you can send it
miami that is so
cool you know what miami because you did
that i'm gonna donate
20 once the stream is done
just to keep the love going that's
amazing that's amazing thank you miami
it's very very nice the humanity of it
yes i like exactly what you're saying
much he's the humanity
just sometimes it's nice to be a nice
person and uh you know yeah
and i mean this not in a streamer but
like smoke up your what kind of way i
mean i really do believe the karma is
real
when you're nice to other people i think
it comes back to you absolutely and
uh just looking at our donations we've
got the great fat boy who donated ten
dollars and said ablegamers is a
fantastic cause
thanks for being awesome and then kay
schlenk
says to marbles on stream and donate 53.
thank you thank you so much do you
recognize this uh this name right here
which one which one the creator of the
map
look at that made by tension who we
haven't shared with us right now
look at that yeah we gotta do that all
right we're gonna do this one all right
let's see
your map tension we're gonna give away
one of my favorite games
in recent memory monster hunter world
iceborn master edition
if you've never played a monster hunter
game this game
is fantastic yeah it is of course for
the playstation
4 which you can play on the playstation
5. a brilliant game
um a game that i was obsessed with for a
really long time
so make sure you hit exclamation mark
play so you can check it out
if you've never played it before yeah
fantastic community
playing still online you'll have a great
time
yeah monster hunter community is so
strong still
even like when did that game come out
they're just resilient like
2019 yeah iterations like some of the
monster hunter
like uh expansions have not been the
greatest they've been kind of
like you know uh yelled at by fans a few
times but they just turn around and they
come back they improve they like
yeah they get better the iceborn's a lot
of fun
and you know you can if you like it you
can check out the one on the switch
which is also
very very good yeah well we got 55
people in this one that was that's our
game high so far lots of people want
monsters
we are under 200 under 200 to go
to our 7 000 goal for this stream so
tinyurl.com
playful 2021 if you're able to donate if
you're not please share the stream
it might you know come into the eyeline
of someone who can
and everything helps and it goes towards
ablegamers an incredible charity
big shout out to blake and madeline
capcom for hooking us up with the
codes um thank you so much look at the
way attention designed this map so that
everybody is just clustered together
yeah everyone's like oh wow
the indy 500 of maps
some people are getting those little
spoony things
the t in in sentien's name is silent
interesting it gives it more mystique i
like that yeah
ascension i like that oh i nearly went
off there yeah you
did i was about to put that key back in
your name there
well that's because we're feeling the
tension from cinch yeah
this is great right here so far this is
good this is real good
oh look at the marshmallow our buddy on
the front
walk mushrooms i'm not saying anything
i'm about to win
a copy of monster hunter
oh man grizzets are not letting it go
though we're not quite ready to give up
we're gonna go slow can anybody get in
front of pork marshmallow what do you
think
good so aggressor is too far away it
seems like unless
you hit that boost though oh oh
is really gaming on oh oh
no oh look at that
well done marshmallow you'd love to see
it
you've got a copy not only do you have
proteus now you've got a copy of monster
hunter
iceborn monsanto world i spawn coming
towards you for the playstation 5.
that was a really close finish that was
a great map oh wait
pogba says i want to give it to personal
munchies
oh okay love to see you wholesome in the
chat
please can you give that uh to personal
munchies that monster hunter code
personal munchies did say it's a game
that
they wanted to play um
a favor for sentient who's been great
and hanging out with us today
if you could type exclamation mark vote
space yes
it helps out sentient getting up the
ranks we can oh
good map yeah yeah let's put some up
votes towards the creation yeah
yeah exclamation mark and vote space
uh wait what did it do i typed in i
typed in exclamation mark
space space
oh wait personal munchie says that ps4
is out of commission
whichever you decide to do whoever wants
to hold on to it
um k goodwin said they also got top ten
for the first time so congratulations oh
yeah
it's anyone's game yes that was a great
map
i liked it i liked it a lot that was
awesome very cool all right
so uh lucy team do you want to do your
your co-host mind meld thing you come up
with another map for us to try from this
smorgasbord of community maps
it's gotta be nine right we did so we've
had six we've had six
okay all right there we go
uh thank you to treygdor for 20
um we are like oh god maths 170 dollars
away from our
7 000 goal every little helps
um tinyrol.com
we're gonna go for stonefly on steam
okay
the game that we're gonna give away
stonefly on steam really cool
interesting game
um worth checking out
in case you're wondering if you're in
twitch you don't have to pay anything
there's nothing to buy no game to do
all you do is type it in chat and then
magically through the power of tam
you join the game pixel by pixel studios
give me the power to do it
i have the power this looks like a very
like
hollow deck like from the star trek era
yeah yeah
i like it okay that's right all right 10
seconds
and there we go
lots of people choosing the alien ball
for this one i think that's really
appropriate
if moonweaver makes it to the top 10
i'll give away a second
code okay okay
your dark souls is showing time
i'm playing favoritism here you are and
i will not apologize for it one
never apologize never explain right okay
oh that was all full i was
attention really going out yeah went too
fast too furious
in theaters thursday uh god i can't wait
same i'm so excited for last night
i'm actually spending 4th of july
weekend watching some more fast and
furious movies with my friends
that is the best way to spend any
holiday
okay tam do you think you can reach all
the way to top five in this
do you believe in yourself i think i can
reach top five okay yeah
oh my god i'm about to go off here right
yeah and now that you've said that
someone's made it imran wins you won one
nine one nice
both ham and lucy made top 10 if they
wanted
they could overpower tam's earlier
decision and just give away that copy
to celebrate them not dying for one yeah
yeah i mean this is a
once in a while i feel like i feel like
what one more i might do
is give away uh another stone fly code
to the second person who was
who is number two second place was mama
higgs
mama hey uh jean-luc i will put the
names of both people
into the document so you have uh imran i
get old city and mama higgs
you get a code each wait time this is
like
dangerously close to you going you get a
code
and you get code i am the video game
oprah
that's right it's been all so much fun
here while we're while we're loading up
the next game i will say
you know my favorite part of doing these
charity streams is always
how people underestimate what good
a little bit of your health can make
so people say to me all the time you
know steve i don't have
twenty dollars to get i don't have a
hundred dollars to give you know it's so
it's not worth it and that's so not true
you know what i always like to do is i
always like to think about these things
as the parable of the starfish have you
ever heard that
no it's such a starfish it's such a
great story for
charity initiatives you know you have a
young boy walking along the beach with
his parents
and the boy stops along the waters and
sees that there's a starfish right
outside the edge of where the ocean can
reach
and he leans down he picks up the
starfish and he throws it back into the
ocean
and this continues down the beach where
they go they find another starfish
that's just outside the reach he throws
it back
in and this continues on and on four or
five starfish later
the dad is just getting super irritated
it's just going
you know why are you doing this this
does not make any difference
and without missing a beat the bully
looks up at the father and goes
but i made a world of difference for the
starfish and that's really what we're
doing here is a little bit of a time
we're making
a world of difference for each one of
these starfish each
one of these people with disabilities
who needs a way to get back into playing
video games
for sure man that is a beautiful story
beautiful way to put it
so please if you can donate ten year
old.com for slash pay for all
we're gonna we're gonna give away mlb
the show 21 for the playstation 4 slash
five
now just came out fairly recently
incredibly well rated
the best uh baseball game around perhaps
even the only baseball
game around uh there's i guess i mean
we're british
there is a few others i believe but emma
be the shoe
21 for the playstation uh exclamation
mark
play you got 20 seconds basically thank
you to family corpse
for the 9.69 with every single one of
you is awesome let's reach
7k thank you for your donation uh we are
just
it's like 160 i think now yeah 160
ish to r7 if you can donate tinyur
playful 2021. five seconds
all right lucy anybody alright first
here's your chance
um colonel sanders
because the gravy in america is not as
good as the gravy
in the uk i'm sorry at kfc specifically
i am sorry to tell you
y'all are not only trying to win but
you're fighting in the shade apparently
all right
in a fight look if i don't use my
platform
to start fast food wars
then what am i doing oh oh look at you
out in first place right now
missing no
i love kfc don't get me wrong i just
want i just want kfc
to be as good worldwide as it is in the
northeast of england
where you can literally just drink that
gravy like a thick
soup i thought you're about to say
milkshake i'll take soup
oh well the karma got back to bite you
in the ass
i got you i got done i deserved that
well we got a cheesy though that's easy
we need to report a robbery because the
jeezy just got
oh man wow benjamin why
1989 you have a copy of mlb the show
21 coming towards you courtesy of
uh john luke and sony thank you
thank you chris heyner wait kfc has
different gravy in the uk tell me more
i'll hit you up on slack but it is it's
like thicker
tastes better it's really it's really
good oh wait
rouchino says in kfc in the philippines
they have a gravy station
with a huge pump what
do you see you can just like the fireman
hose it's just like
you know damn hold these marshmallows
uh and kate goodwin says kfc in scotland
has never failed to disappoint me no
matter how low my expectations
trend versus robots is leaving um thank
you for watching and taking part you've
been great thank you so much
oh and man yeah gravy station we've got
a couple of donations
uh did we read family corpse uh 9.69
okay after that we had susie beagle 20
and then
i'm not almost 20 but that was me
but that was for that was for the uh the
code uh
transfer that happened earlier i
promised i would give twenty dollars and
i did it
so we're 115 away from
uh 7 000 gold and we have like 20 odd
minutes left i think we can hit it
we got this easy we can do this all
right let's spice it up a bit
let's spice it up a bit okay we're gonna
we're gonna give away
another copy of monster hunter world oh
my god
your chances of getting through this map
not good so good luck just like monster
hunter
this is hard mode yeah um
i play i'm gonna use i'm gonna
[Music]
exclamation mark play in the chat if you
want to
join um and yeah playing for a copy of
monster hunter on ps4
if you don't have a ps4 and you do win
that code is yours give it to a friend
donate we've seen a lot of people
donating game codes to other people in
chat it's been a very
very wholesome wednesday so i'm gonna
i'm gonna
challenge you again here chad an hour
ago we tried this and it didn't quite
work i'm gonna i'm gonna double down
here
if either lucy or tam is in the top 10
i'm going to donate ten dollars on my
own personal money to my own cause
at ablegamers uh they pay me
ten dollars every year i'm gonna give it
to you here at this stream if you want
to match me stay in the chat
yeah yeah i'll match that i'll match
that let's go
let's see i make it that's right
matching we got imran matching yeah
thank you to mr dreadful for the dollars
and
40
cents and blazing yeah thanks mate
all right all right everyone be cool
and let tim and i win yeah let us win
at this point it was almost like if lucy
is in this game i will donate ten
dollars
yeah if i don't fall off the edge of the
map well no just in the beginning if you
happen to type
exclamation mark play we'll give ten
dollars
i mean the bar is low for me because i
just fall off
every time i you know there's a joke in
my
my stream where one of my moderators
dies almost every map i believe you have
beaten him he's also from
the uk there must be something about uk
marbles i don't know
if there's something in the water you're
too furious i think that's the thing
yeah yeah
i'm just hoping if i keep name dropping
enough they'll sponsor us eventually
i mean hey i
oh my gosh item
one i'm doubling let's go i'm doubling
my donation
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna double for that
oh yeah i'll i'll donate i'll donate
another time later
who in chat has not played monster
hunter world and would like to play
monster hunter world i'll pick someone
at random
so just just say if you've got a
playstation 4
playstation and you haven't played uh
monster hunter world and you want to
play
montana world just say me you've got 10
seconds
nine eight seven six
five four three two
one zero okay
i'm going to pick someone now and it's
going to be
mobster chief nice you win
you will you'll get my code
mobster chief okay goodman says top
three you can have a tenner for that
thank you oh yeah thank you so much
oh exclamation mark donate in the chat
to bring it up if you wanted to match
i'm doing 20 of my own for 10.
not only like top 10 but it's [ __ ]
winning but for
winning yeah i gave 20 for that
one f-bomb per stream i just used it
sorry
i'll definitely donate as soon as the
stream is done
hell yeah all right tam
would you like to do the honors which
one would you like to play
oh let's do 22 22
okay 22. are you feeling 22
i'm feeling 22. the game we're going to
give away is
mega man 11 mega man 11.
exclamation mark play if you want to
join i love it
don't forget you can put a little number
after the word play if you want to be a
special ball you can
be any one of the ones on the left for
free
your choice
amen number ten year old dot com four
slash play for
2021. we're so close to 7k
we're at nine six thousand nine hundred
and six eight oh we just went
up there uh because we had a donation
came
in from ruchino and imran
and sanchez much lower
okay goodwin goodwin 10 we're making it
we're getting there
surely so close
okay okay we got this all right all
right you're too late to type play now
chats you're just gonna have to hope for
the best
oh we need eight more marbles to hit 69
before the
almost industry next next round yes
we have like three more maps for the end
of streams we're gonna get there
chad find you we've got another we do
have another copy of ratchet and clank
to give away
yes we do yeah all right i thought that
was a squished keanu reeves there for a
second
okay well i'm seeing lots of new names
in chat too
yeah me too yeah nice getting out there
tam if you win again we will have
someone come by to check for me
yeah seriously yeah yeah i do need to go
to the
doctor as well to have my uh balls
checked
i can't wait to get a note from your
overlords after this
gonna slow down you need to stop being
so good ash king's hoarding
not having it says get out of the way
ash maybe too fast though
you get a copy of mega man 11. just make
sure i'm dab
okay i thought for a second that dab
1981 the last copy of mcmahon 11
elderly swimming in mega man 11 cards
uh third boston and sucking really good
ash still top ten we cannot shake ash no
matter what we throw
at them they're always talking is okay
oh wow donations in uh huge thank you
tam matched with the 20 bucks uh trade
door with another twenty dollars
and zach gunnell with a hundred dollars
this stream was too good not to donate
well done all for such an excellent week
thank you exactly
okay celebrate we're gonna give away two
codes for mlb this show
we're gonna give away two calls for mlb
this show um
one on playstation and one on xbox
oh okay so the top two winners of this
can uh specify which one they want it
for
um or i guess the first person to say
what they want it for
gets it and the other one gets the other
one okay yeah all right that sounds good
uh sounds good okay what do you think
what are you feeling maybe an extremely
falling air
i don't know how you extreme fall air
but i would like to find out
i would like to find out also i really
wanted to find out what the aggressive
lasers is but we need the stream for 39
hours to do that so
leave it on in the background find some
bitcoin that's gonna be the game when i
do one weekend it's just
it's 39 absolutely same 39
remember exclamation mark play in the
chat and if you put a number by the side
of it
you get to use one of the marbles on the
left of the screen those are the three
ones
um what have i gone for i think i used
three
yeah i went for three the alien face
slash spider-man venom face
it's an alien yeah it's an alien yeah no
because yeah well then we wouldn't
get copyright issues so there's
definitely a generic alien and not in
any way
um four more three three more chad in
order to get to 69 come on we got this
two more come on chat three more two
more
[Music]
[Music]
uh charity fundraiser rooting hard for
69.69
you kept talking about 69.
oh famicoms tried to go in right at the
end
and just said i blame the stream delay
hate to see it i'm dead already
unbelievable going in for it
two we've got two winners here going at
it yeah
uh copy on playstation and copy on xbox
okay
remember if you win you first want to
say what platform they want
ascension coming in a previous champion
well cinch is winning right now oh my
god
ascension are we gonna get to give him
an extension
and colonel sanders are currently always
good
leads ascension or colonel sanders let
me know which one you want your console
uh what content you want mob for
um
[Music]
even though yeah
yeah i don't know risking
[Music]
i don't have a console oh i hate to see
it well
you could give away again you could give
him a different game or he could give it
to
he she they could give it to a friend
yep you can give it to a friend do you
know someone with a playstation
oh sorry you went you went to xbox yeah
uh the code is coming to you anyway just
you can give it away to someone
make someone else's a day by giving them
a copy of mlb
this show i'm jean-luc both
both that was sentient and colonel
sanders that's right 21. colonel sanders
21.
sarah sarah is like i'm your friend
question mark
oh mr dreadful says if i win can i have
a friend oh
okay the next game we are giving away
is going to be sac boys big adventure
all right then we're gonna we're gonna
do my personal favorite map which is
buckshot it's a quick match it's not
it's not a
it's not a very uh i don't know if
you're a fan of like the robin hood
archery thing it's not a super long map
but you get to run up a skeet shoot and
just throw your marble into a dartboard
i think it's cool all right everyone
let's get to 69.
yep no more no more than 69. if you see
it get to 69 stop
that's right get to 69 right there chad
come on
21. exactly 69 52
55. we're almost there
we're almost come on chat okay come on
now carefully
very very slowly all right don't scare
off the 69
one more stop
it's okay we're all in there now just
get in yeah
colonel sanders came back everyone
this is for sac boys big adventure on
the playstation 5
a fun game a really creative amazing
platformer
it's so fun music is amazing in it as
well
okay asking no you've already won too
much you get out of here
why are you so good at this game
oh oh wow sentient's got some really
cool
like purple blue smoke coming off of him
that's pretty cool
offended again with the girl sanders
let's go oh
yeah you see uh you just go up the uh
little shoots there and it's whoever
gets in the bullseye wins
so oh that's oh it's like um yeah
it's close to the center winds that's
really cool okay
oh it's kind of sanders going to get
another one oh you went far on the
outside well yeah
it went yeah oh no oh some more is
closer
lasagna's even closer lasagna rodrigo
rodrigo no one's touched rodrigo yet
oh look they're great oh dude wait can
you fall off
okay you can fall off apparently yeah
you hit marbles
oh wow okay wow no one's touched rodrigo
rodrigo's got it it looks like rodrigo's
like bang in the center
game just hanging on go okay
oh i think yeah i got it right are
dreadful always the bridesmaid can't
ever yeah
perhaps the most consistent player but
never the winner
but really consistency is either that's
right consistency is key
rodrigo if you're in chat let us know if
you've got a playstation 5 are you
excited to play it
um yeah what a game
here's a here's a really fun one this is
a bongo boogie you have to you get to
play bongo cats as marbles
oh yeah okay we're gonna give away
street fighter
5 champion edition for the playstation
i love this game this is the game that i
want to win this game
so which means even though i i own it
i still want it i just want to write the
code down hug it
yeah yeah exactly yeah
okay chad exclamation mark play it again
it is free if you're watching on youtube
you have to click over a couple yeah let
me check in on youtube
make sure you come over to twitch type
exclamation mark play it's
cost free 100 you just have to type the
word in chat there's nothing else to do
you can pray to the marvel gods that you
win but it doesn't actually
do anything so you know however
if you do donate it's there's no
guarantee it doesn't help
that's all we're saying yeah brandon
hernandez
uh greenzonto zachary twitch chat to
play it won't work if you're in youtube
um i've dropped the link in the bot
should have been dropping the link in
if we have a bot i might just be an
actual person doing it
it's actually been john luke the whole
time the whole time
oh i'm going mad over here doing all
this stuff
yeah before the stream we we did hit him
with like can you do this also this hey
what about doing this
is the real mvp of not only play for all
and charity stuff but like e3
he and eric tay behind the scenes making
sure all the tech stuff goes through
um perfectly and without a floor they
have been incredible
so please show some love for mccain tay
i wish i could uh our
our professional uh marveler currently
really buying susie beagle out there in
front yeah
yeah really trying hard fighting against
the
cruisers
[Music]
on stream she's a really nice human
being he's donated
many times she'll be able to win
[Music]
nowhere routine just
getting in there ruchino you've got a
copy of
355 champion edition for the playstation
coming at ya
well excuse the giggle i'm sorry you
didn't win but i am glad rokino got a
chance to
the first one in the stream today to
celebrate tam's hair and the fact that
we're giving away codes
you know it doesn't look like we've got
many left in us
so we're going to have to crank it up a
notch all right
then the next game we are giving away is
return for the playstation 5.
all right chad that's a good game i'm
going to let you choose exclamation mark
vote space the number of the maps that
you want to play because it's your game
you're the one winning it
so we're just the ones up here that
trying to be funny haha
exclamation mark vote space the number
you want your choice
lucy wants 18 is there something special
about 18 you like oh sorry 16.
16. what do you like about the number 16
it's the last time i felt free
[Laughter]
wow
i just i just like the number 16 because
four four by four is just a nice
it's a two by two just a nice square
number i like it
i don't know why all right that's sir
that's sir all right
all right well kristal says damn i feel
that though
we got a three-way tie right now between
portal purgate
robotic roadway and the delta
oh that delta sounds good delta
here we go this is for
all the marbles and by all the marbles i
mean return all for ps5 mm-hmm
good game good game what did you give
your review
i think we gave it a nine
excuse me it was a hiccup oh
so that last one went to rodrigo 1564
jean-luc
i remember i just realized i didn't hit
a comment on it to put the username
this is the thing that people don't
realize while we're
we're over here doing our thing a lot of
moving parts in the background
oh yeah don't forget chet if you're
gonna play to win like this may be the
second to last map this may be the last
map who knows you're running out of maps
to play
type exclamation marks play right now
yeah let's go
10 seconds 10 seconds to win which one
you wants to shout cast there's
probably second to last map okay yeah
okay i can do this okay yeah time you
got this
leave lucy after finish and they are off
the start
line there all the marbles fanning out
good good idea getting space not
bouncing off at each other we've got
the battle for top spot is heated right
now no one's managed to pull away and
get a
a commanding lead just yet but we do
have dj as charles and
looks like lee is back in there as well
the top 10 full of a bunch of faces
and marbles that we are used to seeing
fox of the future going up and down
quite dramatically
one minute in top five another minute
just out of it entirely
incredible work there um oh this is just
like a standard
race course this is yeah this is evening
the playing field in a lot of ways
no no specific uh kind of uh wild card
whoever gets the third lap first just
says it's simply
a matter of how much did you grease your
marble did you grease it enough
right now it looks like benjamin and dj
are the most
greasy of them all um
must have been from the simpsons was the
grease made up woman grease me up
woman that's my retirement grease
benjamin doing a great job here yeah wow
a lot of people trying to boost in chat
as we said um
doesn't do anything but it will make you
feel better so please do spam
boost if you need to cruise missile
trying to catch up
grid store going in at number one has
all chicken bridge sounds delicious
at number two wow a lot of new faces now
coming in at number one mr dreadful
slowly crawling to the top there
hanging around the middle of the pack a
lot of respect for this dress
sauce cody imagination chicken bridge oh
goodness
oh this is
[Music]
you have won yourself a copy
for the playstation 5. it looks like
we've only got time for one more now
that's right
thanks guys i'm super stoked that's
awesome congratulations
and enjoy we're going to go out with a
bang
the final game we're going to give away
is ratchet and
clank rift apart for the playstation 5.
we kept one in our back pocket for the
grand finale
yeah ratchet and clank
gonna go out with a clank nine out of
ten gamespot.com
potential game of the year contender
that is one of the very strong very fun
ever created
hit exclamation mark play if you're in
youtube hop on over to twitch real quick
hit exclamation mark play maybe donate
some bucks
to tinyworld.com play for all 2021.
for those of you who are new to the
stream and haven't been here with us all
day we are
raising money for evil gamers my name is
steve small i am the chief operating
officer of ablegamers here with my good
friend stan and lucy
we are raising money to help gamers with
disabilities if you haven't been
watching us all day let me remind you
we're not just playing this for fun
and to torture lucy we're actually doing
this to raise money
and in case you're wondering what you do
very simply put ablegamers is the
leading organization out there fighting
for the rights of people with
disabilities in video games when you see
things
like accessibility of the latest call of
duty or any game that you play
where you're like wow those options are
cool ablegamers probably had something
to do with that you can check it out
at ablegamers.org we do a lot of cool
stuff but the most
notable is we go out to hospitals and
individuals people with disabilities and
give
them the equipment that they need thanks
to our peer counseling department at
ablegamers and your donations
so someone wants to play we show them
how and how are we doing it thanks to
your dollars one dollar at a time
right now you can give a dollar if
everybody in chat and youtube gave a
dollar we would hit
7 500 right now think about it one
dollar goes to the cause
this is how you do it the last minute
rally rally together
lucy oh yeah why do you believe in
people with disabilities
i think that it's it's it's an important
thing to support because
it one it helps people generally you
know
combat isolation which everyone has felt
that sense of isolation before and
if you felt that you know how difficult
it can be to overcome it and ablegamers
is
is working hard to combat that but also
i genuinely believe that by
making gaming accessible to people with
disabilities you are
helping the future of video games as a
medium by giving people access to these
games
you're also creating the chance that it
will spark an interest in making games
and if you know organizations like
ablegamers have already
set out the foundation for educating
people on how to
make games that are more accessible and
also you know
giving them the hardware needed to play
it you are investing in the future of
game design and development and that is
i think incredibly important yeah and i
think as well
the fact that if you think about how
many incredible times you've had
playing games over the years like we can
all kind of relate to that as gamers
like you
you spend game you spend time playing
games because you enjoy it you meet
friends you meet communities
you maybe find a career path and it's
like
i guess we've never like i've never had
to think about like what if i couldn't
play a game
right you know i just took it for
granted that i can pick up a controller
and it's totally fine and no adjustments
have to be made for me but that's not
the case for everyone
and then when you kind of realize that
it is the case
you want to spread that enjoyment
and those incredible times with as many
people as possible and so the work that
ablegamers does
not just in like opening up games as a
fun time to people
it's like creating communities and like
i as an adult i think i've met so like
99
of my friends through gaming and that is
such a powerful thing especially in the
last year like that's how i've
communicated with my friends most is
through gaming
and if like if we can help ablegamers by
like raising awareness and obviously
raising money
to an incredible cause because honestly
like the work that you do
is just incredible and it's like it's
not just
one thing that you do it's this
multi-pronged approach to
you know make gaming more accessible in
so many different areas like
peer counseling working with engineers
like working
with game studios to make games more
accessible it's
incredible and so it's so important to
do as well
go to accessible.games right now anybody
who wants to be a developer who is a
developer you can check out that
resource for
free check out uh how you can make games
as accessible as possible to reach
people with disabilities and make sure
you don't leave them out of your game
sir he in contest matt offering matt elf
oh almost
almost fluffy delusions oh my gosh
fluffy lucky delusions there's ben
janker in there at number six as well
so how many people here win games are we
are we going over on this one tim
we're gonna give we're gonna give uh
fluffy delusions
wins ratchet and clank rift apart
and then we're gonna just give away a
bunch of games so jean-luc
get get your fingers ready we're gonna
try and give everyone
we're gonna try and give everyone in the
top 10 a game nice
uh so yeah
what i'll do jean-luc is i'm just going
to resolve
all the existing ones
so that you can have a clearer look at
what remains yeah
lee gabriel in the chat says everyone
who can donate a final dollar go go go
yes
please that would be incredible i'll
read out some uh donations we've just
had
in uh grizzle uh who just won uh one of
the rounds said gave 20
and said yo thank you all so much for
the code i was made aware of ablegamers
and steven tweeted out about the lack of
accessibility in depth by daylight
i firmly believe he made the push for
the devs to add the colorblind modes
the community oh the community was
waiting was wanting for years thank you
all
much love um colonel
sanders uh 20 dollars a great cause and
a fun stream
thank you so much an anonymous 5 eleven
cents real quick uh yeah i this is the
screen i need absolute zero
seven eight nine you're gonna get a copy
of oxen free
and then who's after that we've got
victor lasagna
you're gonna get a copy of oxenfree for
the playstation
and then love
my boston
get a copy of oxenfree for the
playstation
and then who do we have naughty liar
norty leah i really like a wizard
of ogs we need to they've never they've
never played marvel's before
you can see right down below they did
one race we should give where's
the vlogs yeah should give them oxen
free or something yeah uh
uh we're out of oxy but i'll give you uh
a stone fly
nice brick okay and so
naughty leah you're gonna get a copy of
snowflake and then
wizard of ogs the wizard
of orgs you're gonna get a stone fly
and then back up uh ben jenker
you're not getting anything you work
here you work here and that would be
that would get us in trouble yeah that
really would
let's not do that give but you will get
a copy of torchlight 3 for the
playstation
uh just a quick shout out to jean-luc
who's trying to keep track of all this
thank you so much
hang around in chat don't leave chat
yeah if you're one of these people
because it'll make it easier for john
luke
says dreadful
we could give we could give benz to mr
dreadfall
okay mr dreadful you get a copy of
torchlight
uh three heck yeah
uh mr dreadful wait where's your
username
mr dreadful okay spell as is
mr dreadful uh and the final code
of torchlight three it is technically
ash king but i'm sure ash king
wouldn't mind it going to jamie mack 15
since ash king has won
previously uh if if ashkin does mind
i don't care i'm in charge here the
power has gone to his head
wow
15 you get that code um and that's
everything
that's everything done we did it did you
get um mr dreadful
yep mr dreadful is getting a code for
torchlight 3.
awesome uh we got a couple more
donations this last minute uh
matt elfring uh thank you so much matt
with twenty dollars
one up muffin with one dollar lee
gabriel one more dollar uh
grand finale dollar thank you all for
the stream and for all you do for this
cause
and anonymous with twenty dollars
thank you everyone for tuning in and
thank you steve for
putting on a fantastic show for us yeah
um it was amazing it was so fun
that was a lot of fun now tim and i are
both going to pivot
to become esports casters because i
think we were great
but i definitely didn't uh jinx anyone
definitely so play through is going to
continue
we're going to be back in a few hours
we're going to be back from
what is it 2 pm pt um until
4 pm pt so that's 5 p.m et
10 p.m uk time
and we're gonna have uh pro zd
who you may know as a voice actor um
and uh it's gonna be me him and jordan
remain
the anime nerds we're gonna anime boys
yeah we're gonna talk a bit about pro
cds
interesting uh rise to stardom an
incredible person
and then what we're gonna do is i've got
a whole bunch of anime quizzes lined up
i went all around the internet i went to
crunchyroll i went to buzzfeed i went to
various other things and i grabbed so
many viruses now
i've got loads of viruses i grabbed a
bunch of anime quizzes because i've been
really enjoying those like really
cheesy crappy quizzes lately it's been
helping me get through
these uh difficult times so i'm gonna
i'm gonna put those to
pro zd and see how we get on so make
sure you come back
yeah make sure you come back and um yeah
we'll see you then
in the meantime stay safe stay happy and
if you can share the link to donate
around
some friends or people that you know
just spam it and let's try and get some
more money
anywhere.com for all 2021. steve thank
you
so much um you're one of my favorite
people and this was an incredible stream
and you did all the tech stuff in the
back end and so
we appreciate you so much for that i'm
looking forward to sending you the bill
and uh thank you so much
to everybody for supporting uh you know
follow ablegamers on all the socials out
there all around you know
my super shout out to gamespot for
coming in and supporting ablegamers as
well really appreciate that
and uh yeah you all have an amazing day
remember that inclusivity is the way to
make sure everyone has happy